a real pleasure for us to be meeting in
person for the first time in three years
and a real pleasure especially to be
hosted by Christina
managing director of the IMF and her
whole team thank you very much
crystallina for hosting us this time
we have as usual a
excellent cast of speakers all
prominent faces in global finance and
economics
I don't intend to
speak very much at all or in this
introduction
but suffice to say that
this time
it is more complex
it is more complex in every dimension
I noticed that our first panel is called
policy responses and a pandemic and
conflict impacted world but it's not
just the pandemic and it's not just your
political conflict
it is multiple crises affecting rich and
poor within societies
affecting the drivers and the innocent
bystanders affecting low-income
countries and the wealthiest
and it's
not just about a crisis today it's not
just about multiple crises today
it's about an era
that we have entered
an era of enduring uncertainty and
fragility
and we have to find bases for optimism
in this era real BCS for optimism not
just rhetorical but bases for investment
for growth for collaboration and above
everything else
bases for tackling the overriding
challenge of the Global Commons
and I'd like to start by requesting
crystallina
to give us a
perspective that addresses the themes of
both our panels the first panel being
that focused on monetary and fiscal
policy and macroeconomic policy in
general and the second panel
concerning a very worrying Prospect of
that distress
in several regions of the World
Christina thank you
thank you thank you very much Tarman it
is very uh
telling that
the tougher
the environment becomes the easier it is
for people to remember my last name and
pronounce it correctly
uh and it is because indeed the IMF
is a contraceptical institution by the
nature of our mandate uh any we are in a
particularly uh complex time today
it is
a fundamental shift
from the last Decades of relative
predictability
that
led us to enjoy the benefits of a
rule-based international order
translating into improvements in
standards of living for
hundreds of millions of people
low inflation low interest rates
to a period of time of much higher
volatility
a
period of geopolitical tensions and
risks of fragmentation of the world
economy
and what we are experiencing right now
High inflation High interest rates that
demand uh the focus of attention of
policy makers and this is what happened
during this week
what gives me ground for optimism is the
unity of purpose
we have
Pursuit
during the meetings and the fact that we
are coming out of the meetings with a
much clearer focus of what is necessary
to stabilize the world economy and put
it on a sound footing for tomorrow not
easy
but clear
so what is the path in this Spirit of
uncertainty that we can foresee we have
to step on
first a recognition that
inflation is a tremendous risk
for growth and well-being of people and
therefore we have to focus on winning
the fight against it for central banks
almost everywhere Corrado sand Japan is
this a healthy exception
and now at the time when they have to
uh increase interest rates
in a consistent and prudent manner
to bring inflation down and most
importantly retain inflation
expectations well anchored
second
we have a clear recognition that we are
in a much more complex policy
environment today than we were in 2020
when once we diagnosed the economic
Fallout from covet
we had monetary policy and fiscal policy
all working in the same direction of
accommodation whereas today monetary
policy Titans whereas
fiscal policy has to recognize the
hardship on people and come up with well
targeted and temporary measures to
support the most vulnerable
and there we got a very strong call from
our membership
for the fund to be specific in our
bilateral surveillance what exactly we
mean by targeted and temporary measures
and use our multilateral surveillance
for our members to share experience and
learn from each other
three there was a recognition that risks
to financial stability are growing a
rapid and disorderly repricing of assets
could be magnified by existing
vulnerabilities such as high public debt
and also
uh poor liquidity in some parts of the
financial Market
for
we recognize that what makes economies
strong is the Relentless pursuit of
structural reforms and I remind people
my predecessor our fantastic
Christine Lagarde saying when the sun is
shining fix the roof remember this
message
yes okay so here I am coming in her
footstep and saying uh those who haven't
fixed the roof when the sun is shining
now it is pouring you guys better get up
there and fix it and actually uh uh jock
on the side it is Paramount uh to have
strong fundamentals in a more shock
prone world we are now going to be
living
um
and last but not least there was a very
clear recognition that emerging markets
and developing economies are at
particularly high risk they are being
hit by
High footen Energy prices
High inflation and on top of it strong
dollar
the high level of debt for many of them
it has gone up during covet and the high
costs of servicing this that at the time
of interest rates are climbing
and that recognition that we have to
mobilize to support emerging markets and
developing economies especially the IMF
and the multilateral development Banks
our responsibility to do it has been
very clear
uh it also brought a message to a major
central banks especially to the FED I
want to quote the minister of finance of
Nigeria who said I wake up every morning
thinking about what the fed maybe may
have done and that is a reality for for
emerging markets it also puts a an extra
responsibility to set two major Center
Banks how they communicate but also to
the fund what we do
so we are in that a place of recognizing
that stabilizing the world economy is
possible but only if we have prudent
policy response and if we work together
uh I want to tell you what we are mostly
worried at the front and it is uh
missteps it is very unfortunately at the
time of uncertainty
the probability of making a mistake
policy mistake is is high and we have to
recognize that may happen and that
corrective measures would be then
appropriate and that we have a
responsibility as an institution to keep
a mirror in front of our members so they
can see themselves uh clearly you know
Columbia here get your makeup uh do do
what is necessary uh as you see your
your your uh your situation clearly I
want to make a point that the meetings
were actually quite uplifting on
recognizing that there are challenges we
can only address working together yes
there is geopolitical attention yes it
translates into geo-economic
fragmentation but there are areas where
the world
simply cannot succeed without us working
together climate change
quite encouraging this week to see that
we are pulling and the fund of course is
taking our responsibility we are today a
systemically significant institution in
the fight of climate change and I want
to recognize our membership for giving
us this mandate to be so from policies
to financing with our new resilience and
sustainability trust I saw that Finance
Minister Nazi Nazism manner I apologize
jamana okay
now I proved that I am very easy to
accept people not pronouncing my my name
correctly because I you know I they're
all in my mouth with difficulty but he's
a great great Minister from Rwanda he is
on one of the panels Randa is one of the
first three countries to benefit from
the resilience and sustainability uh
trust
we also know that we cannot get anywhere
on that unless we work together
we have made some progress with the
common framework we now have Zambia and
chat the issue for us is how to cement
a rule for the common framework that
gives predictability to countries so
they come to it and also that brings
both public and private sector lenders
together with the debtors for early
resolution uh given where we are with
high level of debt uh distress we also
saw the issue of digitalization and
cross-border payments in this new era
coming up as a unifier where we can work
together with bis with FSB the IMF
stepping cup
and last but not least
what I got from the meetings is this
sense that people are looking at the IMF
and saying okay now you guys are on the
front line they demonstrate that you are
clear about your role as a firefighter
we are clear about this role first we
take responsibility for our analysis to
be precise and and honest
at the global level and for countries
to speak truth to power second we
recognize our responsibility to be a
financier
when the situation is tough we still
have 700 billion dollars capacity I can
tell you that countries are coming in
much larger numbers to the fund and
rightly so they're doing the right thing
we have funded 16 countries with about
90 billion dollars since uh February
24th since the war started and we have
about 28 requests I'm actually today
going to be meeting with delegations of
Egypt and Tunisia countries where I'm
confident you would see us backing them
up in this difficult time we also think
of how we can expand our Landing
capacity through on lending of sdrs you
know the numbers we we the word said 100
billion is fair to transfer through the
fund on concessional basis we are at 80
billion uh and I actually would say this
France went from 20 to 30 of sdrs
why not others
um I Heard Japan saying we are thinking
about maybe doing more in a tough time
sdrs we have distributed to our members
uh last year with the 650 billion
dollars allocation for those who have
Strong Reserve position these sdrs are
like a Sleeping Beauty
and I think it is time for the prince to
to provide the necessary kiss and I
think tough economic conditions this is
our our Prince uh we we are also
um here to bring everybody together I
just came from a meeting of the
presidents of multilateral development
Banks we have to prove that the
multilateral system is one where the
hole is bigger than the sum of
individual Parts I finished my speaking
to the imfc yesterday we were running
out of time I wanted to be very short so
here is my summing up buckle up and keep
going
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'd like to ask the panelists for panel
one to please come up and join us on
stage please
no I couldn't stand in your shoes uh
Jacob don't worry thank you very much
is the mic working
it's fine okay thank you very much
crystallina
for those
candid observations and for your
leadership and the IMs leadership
in
finding a way for the ship to reach
Harbor
um I'm not going to introduce our
speakers individually we know them all
starting with Andrew Bailey
the central Banker of the moment if I
might say
foreign
Jacob Frankel who co-charged the
international banking seminar for me in
his capacity is the person who leads the
Board of Trustees of the group of 30.
um class not
only the
governor of the judge Central Bank but
also fsp chair and Nile Ferguson
decidedly not a central Banker or not
yet a central Banker
provide a
um shall I say now for something really
different
so we're going to start with krudoza
please oh
nice speak here
um I
I think for Speed why don't we are you
okay speeding here
thank you thank you Mr Talma
today I would like would you prefer to
speak oh yeah
because of the notes it makes it
countless
yes yes it's okay thank you Mr Taman
today I would like to talk about policy
responses since the pandemic began
mainly in the context of Japan's
monetary policy let me start with the
policy responses to the acute shock
posed by the pandemic
in the wake of the covid-19
outbreak the bank of Japan acted
minimally to stabilize financial markets
through the Ampro supply of Fund in
addition to the provision of young funds
the provision of U.S dollar fund through
cooperation with five other major
central banks was extremely effective
to support corporate financing the bank
of Japan substantially increased its
purchases of commercial paper and
corporate bonds
furthermore a new facility was
introduced to provide funds on favorable
terms to financial institutions that
made loans in response to the pandemic
other central banks also implemented
measures to stabilize financial markets
and support corporate financing as a
result tensions in Global Financial
markets East and bankruptcies remained
at low levels these measures Drew on
lessened land from the global financial
crisis I believe that the experience
gained from the crisis
where liquidity was provided in a timely
manner on a global basis in response to
the acute Global shock was useful in
addressing the racist crisis as
economies have gradually reopened the
role of such pandemic responses is
coming to an end in fact the bank of
Japan decided last month to phase out
the facility
looking back Central bank's responses to
the pandemic were oriented in the same
direction One to support corporate
financing to to conduct monetary easing
to support the economy
however
people's responses to the reopening of
the economy have had unexpected effect
on both demand and supply for example
vigilance against covid-19 has had a
known negligible impact on consumption
behavior and labor Supply furthermore
the war in Ukraine has had a significant
impact on the surprise side
against this backdrop many central banks
have changed the direction of their
monetary policy
for instance in the United States and
Europe central banks have shifted to
fighting inflation that has risen to
nearly 10 percent on the other hand
while Hydra inflation in Japan is above
the price of the target of two percent
this is mainly due to cost push factors
from abroads such as rising energy on
the food prices
when excluding all of those factors
inflation runs at 0.7 percent
since headline inflation is expected to
fall below two percent next fiscal year
the boj is continuing with monetary
easing
I've now explained the differences in
price dynamics that underlie the policy
defined differences between Japan on the
one hand and the US and Europe on the
other focusing on three aspects first
the upward pressure on prices from
demand side is smaller in Japan while
GDP in the U.S and Europe is clearly
above the pre-pandemic level Japan's DB
has not yet
recovered through such a such a level
this is because I've seen in the fact
that most people still
wear masks in Japan Vigilant against
Kobe 19's deep seated especially among
seniors and Recovery in private
consumption has been moderate
this contrasts with the United States
where private consumption including
dining out on travel has been vigorous
as consumers are using savings that had
built up during the pandemic in short
the momentum of economic recovery from
the pandemic has depended on differences
in consumer consumers responses second
there are differences in the labor
market adjustment process in the wake of
the pandemic in Japan
through Farms holded labor during the
pandemic supported by government
subsidies as a result geographies were
limited in addition in contrast to
consumption the impact of the pandemic
on labor Supply in Japan was smaller
than in the United States and the labor
force participation rate already
exceeded the pre-pandemic level
on the other hand in the United States
changes in Behavior due to the pandemic
have triggered the great retirement or
great resignation another result the
recovery in labor supply has been slow
and the labor force participation rate
has not yet recovered to its pandemic
level this has led to an unprecedented
rapid tightening of the labor market in
the U.S the third is wage price Dynamics
the sharp rise in a wide range of
commodity prices due to war in Ukraine
has prolonged the high inflation
in the United States and Europe fears
about the anchoring of inflation
expectations
or over wage price spiral have surfaced
such Dynamics were observed during the
great inflation
that said a virtuous cycle between wages
and prices is essential for Price
stability the problem facing Japan is
that this cycle
broke down with the collapse of the
barber economy in the 1990s a major
shock that led to prolonged deflation
from 1998 through 2012.
Farms have focused on securing demand
for holding down selling prices and have
observed costs increases by improving
productivity in this way they have
withheld from Raising prices on both
labor and management have favored
Improvement stability and avoided
raising wages in other words prices and
wage setting based on the assumption
that prices
will not rise has become
the norm and deeply entrenched the boj
has been conducting qqe to emit the
challenge of changing this norm and
restoring the virtual cycle between
wages and prices
nearly a decade of qqe together with
government measures has steadily
improved economic and the employment
situation even though the price
stability target has not been achieved
in a sustainable State stable manner the
influential rate has been positive
territory and there have been signs of
change in the mindset regarding prices
and wages as reflected for example in
the increase in base pay for nine
consecutive years
given these three aspects of current
Dynamics
in Japan WJ considered it appropriate to
continue with monetizing to support the
economy to ensure a shift in norms and
to ensure the price stability Target in
a sustainable and stable manner
accompanied by wage increases finally uh
the pandemic and conflicts are ongoing
risks factors for uh for some time and
may bring about structural changes the
pandemic and consequence changes in
digitalization have affected the
structure of the economy
and the way people work moreover from a
broader perspective it is possible that
conflict around the world may affect the
trend of globalization which has been a
major aging engine of global economic
growth
so depending on how household and firms
respond to these changes factors such as
medium to long-term growth expectations
potential growth rate output Gap may be
affected so
central banks need to carefully examine
the mechanisms through which these risk
factors affect demand and supply and
conduct policies based on the premise of
a large degree of uncertainty this will
continue to be a major challenge for the
conduct of monetary policy thank you
thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much
we now move to class and class if you
could touch not just for the European
situation but make some observations on
the
spillovers that we are seeing for the
developing world
okay yes siren I would be happy to do so
but I also had a couple of slight and
I think you press the green button yeah
yeah
so good morning to all of you uh and uh
thanks for inviting me on this uh on
this panel on the global economy and
Global Financial stability uh not to say
the least here and my starting point is
actually this very much the same as also
the starting point of Corona song and
that is that high inflation has been set
off by a mixture of global shocks the
pandemic first created a supply chain
restrictions pushing up inflation which
was then subsequently reinforced by
strong pent-up demand and for the Euro
area this strong demand effect in the
first half of this year was clearly an
upward surprise to us a pleasant one but
that's where it more or less ended
um and a similar pattern can actually be
observed if you look at the consequences
of the energy crisis as a result of
Russia's unjustifiable war in Ukraine
the disrupted energy Supply it's a
classic negative Supply shock leading to
elevated energy crisis but then the
government came in they've responded
with extensive fiscal measures which
then tend to support demand now it's
been a recurrent theme of these meetings
here over the last few days that if the
scope of these support measures becomes
too broad
too permanent uh and uh and and
insufficiently funded if I can put it
like that then clearly yeah this will
constitute an other upside risk to uh
inflation
but what is important I think to realize
is that the impact of the shock that
differs per uh region in the Euro area
pent of demand has clearly been less
dominant than in the United States
simply because the fiscal response to
the pandemic has been more moderate in
the Euro area but on the other end Euro
area is more affected by natural gas
supply disruptions unlike the US who is
a main energy producer itself and these
differences clearly show up in the
drives of inflation and this is a simple
structural VAR model that shows that the
picture in the Euro area is clearly more
balanced when it comes to supply and
demand effects if you were to do this
picture for for the United States you
would probably see a lot more green and
somewhat less blue
due to this configurational shocks
inflation has turned out higher and also
more persistent than previously was
projected according to our Baseline
projection uh within the ECB inflation
in the Euro area remains far too high
and is likely to stay above our two
percent Target for an extended period of
time
model projections are of course the
Cornerstone of our decision making but
they are only one input and especially
in these times of successive shocks that
are not and and by definition cannot be
fully captured by the models that
underlie these projections so the
unprecedented economic conditions imply
a very high degree of uncertainty for
inflation Dynamics where we then also
have to focus on what happens with
underlying inflation Trends and there in
the Euro area we have clearly seen a
broadening of inflationary forces since
mid 2021 with clear and strong price
Dynamics in a wide range of goods and
services taken in place taking inflation
to 10 headline in September and this
broadening is clearly also reflected in
core inflation core inflation was always
around one percent for almost 10 years
up until mid 2021 but now over the last
year it rapidly shot up to 4.8 percent
in September and I'm afraid we haven't
seen the peak of that yet
other indicators for underlying
inflation measures that reflect common
drives of inflation confirm this
evolution of inflation uh as well
in this environment of course we should
be vigilant for a waste wage price uh
spiral and it's good to keep in mind
that in many Euro area countries
actually a lot of wage negotiations take
place in the fall
there are signs of stronger
substantially higher wage demands and
some of which have already also been met
and while incidental inflation
compensation is perhaps uh yeah it's
very sensitive to support uh purchasing
power
especially where wage growth has lacked
productivity growth inflation will of
course become more entrenched if High
wage increases become a repeat
prescription
so to prevent such vicious Dynamics
central banks will have no choice but to
act according to their mandate to keep
inflation expectations anchored
and similarly targeted fiscal support to
Shield those that are the most
vulnerable to the high inflation is
absolutely welcome but broader fiscal
stimulus as I already hinted at will
push up demand and will simply
counteract the course of monetary policy
and if that were to happen in that case
two central banks will simply have no
choice but to act according to the
mandate to keep inflation expectations
anchored
when inflation is projected to stay
above Target and economic growth is
constrained by inelastic supply
it's clear that monetary policy cannot
maintain its expansionary posture that
has been in place for over a decade now
and given this inflation Outlook we
first have to take interest rates back
to levels that bring the economy back in
equilibrium to keep also our the
expectations aligned with our two
percent Target
in December 2021 the ECB started
normalizing its 103 policy by announcing
the end of net asset purchases and
several months later the net asset
purchases were also concluded the pep in
March and the app in July
policy rates have been raised in two
large steps now and we expect to
increase them further over the coming
months
financial markets have obviously
anticipated this as is reflected also in
the strong rise of bond yields since
early 2022.
now as a first steps we will increase
policy rates to a level that will
provide us with sufficient comfort that
we have entered the range of plausible
estimates for neutral
while the precise level of the neutral
interest rate is of course shrouded by
uncertainty it is clear that at current
levels we're not there yet
in any case I am fully convinced that we
need to do more than just removing
accommodation to fulfill our price
stability mandate
indeed the uncertain macroeconomic
environment with clear and present
upside risks to inflation calls for a
risk management approach a risk
management approach that would ER on the
side of resolve
in line with our strategy review the
larger the risks of inflation
expectations moving away from our two
percent Target the more forceful our
response will simply have to be
for now and for the next few months we
will just be guided onwards and upwards
by our data dependent and meeting by
meeting approach
and I should add that I do not expect
policy rates rate hikes to come to an
abrupt end but it is also true that the
farther we hike and the closer we come
to restoring a credible Prospect of
inflation moving back to Target the
smaller future rate steps will likely
become
the level to which the policy rate will
have to be increased also depends of
course on the calibration of all the
tools including the runoff of the
central bank balance sheet once we have
reached neutral territory with our
policy rate it makes sense to consider
the roll-off of asset purchases by
limiting reinvestments and this would
help transmitting our tighter monetary
policy also evenly across the entire
yield curve and ensure that all monetary
instruments work in the same direction
model model simulations indicate that
lifting the policy rate in tandem with
an upward term premium effect helps to
reach the target more efficiently as it
lowers both Peak inflation and also the
required terminal rate
I do believe however that we should move
gradually here and to this end it also
makes sense to distinguish between our
two asset purchase portfolios app and
pep the asset purchase program and the
pandemic emergency purchase program the
former is an instrument exclusively to
stay at the monetary stones and should
therefore simply be seen as a complement
to the policy rate
but the pep plays a dual rate in a dual
role in our toolbox by also countering
serious risks to monetary transmission
related to the pandemic and it implies
that decisions about unwinding these
programs do not have to run in parallel
per se
now finally on monetary policy to ensure
that The Stance is also transmitted
smoothly across all Euro area countries
the transmission protection instrument
was introduced in July 2022
it supports price stability in the Euro
area as a whole while preventing
unwarranted disorderly market dynamics
the combination of peps built in
flexibility with respect to
reinvestments
the newly created TPI the already
existing outright monetary transactions
that makes for a richly filled toolbox
to counter any unwarranted disorderly
market dynamics that would in turn
threaten to derail the pursuit of our
price stability mandate
now that is all I have to say on
monetary policy thumb and you asked me
to also say a few words on Global
Financial stability
it is crystal clear that of course this
sort of situation that we are in very
high inflation
slowing growth and rapidly Rising
financing costs everywhere in the
economy that's the situation we haven't
seen for 40 years it sort of brings some
vulnerabilities to the four that were
already there for much longer but will
now become much more urgent
high debt levels the next panel is on
that so I won't elaborate too much on it
but it's clear in some countries it's
about household debt in other ones it's
about corporate debt The Sovereign that
issue but that is the next panel another
area that worries me a lot I must say is
the non-bank financial intermediary
space if you look at the most of the
financial instability events of the last
two years or so be it the dash for cash
be it the issues surrounding commodity
trading be it the issues surrounding
Pension funds in the UK
it all has to do with sort of pockets of
hidden leverage that pop up in the
system
because the system is on the string and
that's logical that system is on the
strain because in the financial system
there are a lot of business models risk
management strategies that were built on
the low for long and probably on an
expectation that low would be very long
and longer than has proven to be the
case but it's very clear that there are
strains in this area and that we need to
beef up the work also within the
financial stability board to make these
pockets of hidden leverage have a more
systematic sort of stock take of where
they could pop up and what to do about
it and then finally with an eye to the
Emerging Markets of course a third
vulnerability is the foreign currency
debt issue it's a persistent
vulnerability it has been around for
long but also that is of course now only
increase with any rise in in interest
rates in the advanced world so I'll
leave it with that senatorman and then
of course I'm ready for questions later
yeah thank you
thank you very much class and now we're
going to move to Andrew
well thank you very much Tom and can I
add my
um
congratulations to bringing the G30
together again in person it's really
very welcome
we are of course getting together in
person and what are really the most
difficult at times as others have said
and I think in saying that we should
recognize that however difficult each of
our positions is and we can all describe
that nothing compares to the suffering
Afflicted on the people of Ukraine
I think in these times I've personally
always feel that a large measure of
stoicism has called for
and particularly the view of the Stokes
that the best indication is what we do
and how we behave rather than what we
say but there is an important role for
communication and so I will set out the
key elements of UK marching Financial
stability policy as I certainly see them
just as others have described the UK
economy has been buffeted by very large
disturbances in the last two and a half
years or so
there I would point to covid the supply
chain issues in the covert recovery
a shrinkage of the labor force during
this period
and most recently of course the impact
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine on
energy and other commodity prices
and these disturbances are very large
in the UK the rise in Energy prices
means that household spending on energy
as a share of income could plausibly be
a full two percentage points higher this
winter than in 2019.
and this is bigger than any annual
increase we saw in the energy crises in
in the 1970s
disturbances that have come since covert
had been supply side effects in the UK
Supply chains shrinkage of the labor
force Cuts in the supply of natural gas
to Europe as a whole
and I want to draw out a number of
points from this to start with
the first is that when you look at
overall activity in the UK UK economy it
has not experienced a rapid and
sustained recovery from the covert
disturbance
the level of GDP on the latest reading
remains below the pre-covered level
and the problem then is that the supply
side has shrunk particularly the labor
force and the economy has been hit as I
said by a huge shock to National real
income from the war
now second and it is said that central
banks and I also include the bank of
England this were incorrect a year or so
ago to emphasize the transient nature of
these shocks and thus how monetary
policy should respond
my response to that is sort of no and
yes really no in the sense that the
monetary policy prescription for how to
respond to a single transient Supply
shot was the correct one but yes because
what we didn't see was a sequence of
such shocks to come without gaps which
invalidated the basis of the transient
transient arguments
because the combined duration of these
shocks has kept inflation elevated for
an uncomfortably long period of time
given the potential implications for
medium-term inflation expectations
though I would say of course that I
think when all of us were participating
in this event virtually last year it was
hard to see of course the uh and predict
Russia's Behavior
third and I think this is harder and
where I'm sure economic historians will
find very interesting issues to dissect
could we have foreseen the shrinkage of
the labor force and the persistently low
level of unemployment despite the
prevailing disturbances
I'm not going to judge this but I will
say that I think the two questions that
really wait for me here are could we
reasonably have foreseen at the time
that the high level of inactivity in the
labor force would persist
even as the pandemic wound went down
because I hope it's whacking that
and should we have been more sun going
at the end of a furlough scheme which
covered a million jobs up to the end
would have no discernible impact on on
unemployment
but that's really all history it shapes
where we are today though
meanwhile of course Russia has
perpetrated its illegal invasion of
Ukraine setting off the disturbance that
has run through the world economy
for the UK as I noted earlier and for
many other countries it has been a huge
negative shock to real income
and to the position of households and
businesses
it affects most severely the most
vulnerable and least well-off because
energy has a necessity of life
is a much larger part of their
consumption
and for us at the bank of England it's
created a huge challenge for monetary
policy because inflation is of course
well above its two percent Target
in early August we estimated that the
Direct effects of higher energy prices
That's not including the indirect
effects such as stress would contribute
around six and a half percentage points
to inflation towards the end of this
year
our assessment then was that inflation
would Peak around 13 and then come down
sharply other things equal to the two
percent Target in two years time before
falling further to bid under one percent
in three years
now much of the discussion then in the
MPC was around how equal are the things
really would be
to what extent would the tightness of
the labor market exacerbate the impact
of energy prices on inflation
expectations and thus cause higher
inflation to be more persistent
meanwhile the impact of the energy price
shock has throughout Europe and Beyond
posed a huge challenge for governments
and for fiscal policy
and the consequences of the shot for
people are huge and disturbing
governments have naturally responded
the UK government has introduced a
two-year price cap for domestic
household Energy prices and a six-month
cap for businesses
this is a major intervention but it's
understandable
the consequences for monetary policy are
important
it should cap the peak of inflation we
think at around 11 and it should lead to
a more rapid fall in inflation back
towards targets
and other things ought to be more equal
because there is greater confidence in
the profile of Retail Energy prices
During the period on which monetary
policy focuses
but I should stress that of course it
remains to be seen whether other things
really will be more equal we can't take
that for granted I'm afraid
and we will have to keep a very close
eye on that situation
now the price cut will add to demand
relative to what it would have been
without the cap and thus what we thought
in August
it will therefore add to inflationary
pressures towards the later part of the
two-year period on which we focus
this is the point at which we thought
inflation would come down to and then go
below Target
lastly on this we also have to think
about what energy prices will be when
the cap is lifted
now more recently the UK government has
made a number of fiscal announcements
and is set October the 31st as the date
for a further fiscal statement
the NPC will respond to all this news at
its next meeting in just under three
weeks from now
just after the 31st of October
this is the correct sequence in my view
we will know the full scope of fiscal
policy by then
but I repeat what what I've said already
we will not hesitate to raise interest
rates to meet the inflation Target and
as things stand today my best guess is
that inflationary pressures will require
a stronger response than we perhaps
fought in August
now you take financial markets have
experienced some violent moves in the
last few weeks particularly at the long
end of the government debt Market
and this has put the spotlight on the
floor floors in the strategy and
structure of one important part of a lot
of Pension funds this class referred to
the bank of England we've had to
intervene to deal with a threat to the
stability of the financial system our
other core objective
now there may appear to be a tension
here between tightening monetary policy
as we must
including so-called quantitative
tightening and buying and buying
government debt to ease a critical
threat to financial stability
and this explains why we've been clear
that our interventions on the latter
Point are strictly temporary and have
been designed to do the minimum possible
or necessary
so I want to end my remarks by drawing
on this experience to make the
distinction between monetary policy and
financial stability interventions
let me start by saying that as a central
bank we have to be able to do both at
any time
we cannot decline to do one because it
appears to be at odds with the other
for me the test is whether we can still
operate each policy in accordance with
his subjectives at all times
and the answer for me during this period
has been yes
but let me elaborate on the difference
between the two with three important
points
I'll start the first the first is one of
definition
monetary policy should be seen as the
active setting of interest rates or more
broadly influencing risk-free or
risk-free yields in order to meet the
inflation objective given prevailing
economic conditions
Financial policy meanwhile has a broad
sweep in the context of our recent guilt
market operations it is aimed at
preventing overall Financial stability
from being threatened by severe
dislocations in some financial markets
it's not about steering Market yields
towards some particular level but rather
preventing them from being distorted by
market dysfunction
now that distinction may not be always
be as clear in practice as it is in
principle but on this occasion I think
it was
the jump in long-term meals in the hours
before our intervention was accompanied
by a sharp widening in Bidar spreads
for shorter maturities historically the
more liquid part of the market
both yields and spreads move
significantly yes
we've had a very clear message from
Market partisan participants about the
stability threatening dynamics of this
process
on that first day it took only a small
number of purchases to reduce the
30-year yield very significantly
so all this suggests that whatever the
fundamentals the particular behavior of
the long end of the curve was caused by
a liquidity event
second the operational details also
differ significantly
the NPC's decisions on QE have targeted
a specific stock of asset Holdings
but for financial stability purposes
we're not looking to buy any particular
amount or Capital control yields
our aim was to restore liquidity and to
provide time for so-called
liability-driven investment funds to
reduce Leverage
unlike qer Financial stability operation
was very much a short-term one it ended
yesterday after only two weeks of
operation
the third last point is that the MPC is
not using the stock of asset Holdings as
an active tool of monetary policy at
present
as we've made clear over a number of
years once Bankrate was away from the
lower bound and could move in both
directions the intention was to unwind
the stock of QE gradually and
predictably and in a way that wasn't
bound to underlying economic conditions
because instead monetary conditions are
now steered by bank rate
the primary instrument of policy
and should monetary conditions prove too
loose to meet the inflation Target given
the economic news its bank rate that
responds
and whatever the source of any
disturbance to monetary conditions the
NPC is free to offset these disturbances
by means of its primary instrument bank
rate
but I'll just end by saying that I think
this example in this case study if you
like shows that in difficult times we
need to be very clear on this framework
of intervention thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you Andrew that that was
very clear thank you over to you now
would you prefer to speak from yeah
well Simon you you promised something
completely different
uh may I remind you that Monty Python
which made those words famous aired
between 1969 and 1974 significant dates
I must say I wish Paul volcker were here
I suspect I'm not the only person in
this room who misses him now more than
ever I really hope he would have
approved of what I'm going to say
during the interwar era in other words
the period between Cold War one and Cold
War II
many economists and policy makers lost
sight of the role of war in the global
economy
as of the interwar era were quite small
Bosnia Afghanistan Iraq more closely
resembling Colonial policing operations
we forgot that war is history's most
consistent driver of inflation debt
defaults even famines
and that's because large-scale war is
simultaneously destructive of productive
capacity disruptive of trade and
destabilizing a fiscal and monetary
policies
if you plot Global battle deaths from
Interstate conflict against inflation
I'd have produced a slide to show this
if I'd known slides were allowed
you'll see at the behind the so-called
great moderation there was a period of
declining global conflict that lasted
from the mid 70s actually until the
outbreak of the war in Ukraine
the coming of Peace like monetary policy
acted with a lag
the events of this year have reminded us
what's at stake in cases of great power
conflict the war in Ukraine qualifies as
such a conflict because Russia is still
clearly a great enough power that it
would by now likely have achieved its
annexationist aims had it not been for
large-scale financial and Military not
to mention technological assistance to
Ukraine from the United States the
European Union the United Kingdom and
other Associated States this is a big
war measured by both casualties and
costs
now the economic importance of wars and
especially world wars was highlighted
some Years Ago by a barrow and Ursula
paper from 2008 of the 70 consumption
and output disasters they identified for
oecd countries
fully a third were War related
in a new paper which I've co-authored
with Martin Connor you Paul schmeltzing
and Mark schuleric based on four
centuries of data we show that central
bank balance sheets have very often
expanded in response to geopolitical as
well as Financial crises they didn't
call it quantitative easing back then
now economists like to treat or tend to
treat Wars as exogenous shocks because
they're kind of hard to model but from
the historian standpoint War isn't
exogenous it's the endogenous prime
mover of the historical process the
father of all things as heraclitus
famously said
so two general points are really
important to notice
first Wars have played a very noticeable
role in the history of inflation
expectations thanks to the excellent
historical work of the bank of England
we can trace the history of UK inflation
expectations all the way back to the
late 17th century the peaks in short-run
expectation uh nearly all align with
Wars and generally years when the war
wasn't going well 1709 wore a Spanish
succession
1757 the Seven Years War 1800 Napoleonic
Wars 1917 1940 1975 is the exception but
you could link that to the consequences
of the 1973 arab-israeli War
second point is that Wars have often
been responsible for discontinuities in
the history of interest rates
as Paul schweltzing has argued work that
the bank of England first published
there's been a long-term suprasecular
stagnation meaning a downward Trend in
nominal and real long-term rates dating
back to the period after the black death
which was of course almost certainly the
biggest pandemic in history
the major breaks in that long downward
Trend were nearly all associated with
Wars particularly big Wars that
destroyed Capital stock and generated
monetary financing of debt
now an unusual feature of the recent
past is that in 2020 a pandemic had the
fiscal and monetary consequences of a
World War this was unprecedented no
previous pandemic including the much
more devastating
1918-19 Spanish influenza had comparable
responses from Finance Ministries and
central banks
because most not all but most countries
followed the United States in offsetting
the supply shock caused by lockdowns and
spontaneous behavioral changes with both
large-scale deficit Finance transfers
and significant monetary expansion the
first pandemic year was associated with
extraordinarily large deficits and
monetary growth rates actually
comparable with those of world wars it's
hard to find any precedent for that in
the history of past pandemics
unfortunately major policy errors were
committed in the second plague year of
2021 the newly elected Biden
Administration embarked on an
over-ambitious transformative fiscal
stimulus while the Federal Reserve
retained its accommodative stance even
as the rapid rollout of Highly
efficacious vaccines permitted a return
to normal social and economic behavior
like those who thought the pandemic
would last forever those who argued that
inflation would be transitory like at
the end of World War II turned out to be
wrong
those who saw a better analogy with the
fed's great mistake Alan meltz's phrase
of 1968 have actually been Vindicated by
the Persistence of inflation
most accounts of the great inflation of
the 1970s tend to underestimate the role
that war played if I had more time I'd
go into that it's not just about 1973
it's also about Vietnam and other
conflicts of the 1970s
in 2022 a war played an analogous role
to The War of 1973 in pouring kerosene
on an inflationary fire that was already
burning both food and energy prices were
driven up by the outbreak of the war and
the sanctions imposed on Russia by the
U.S and others
it goes without saying I think that the
return of great power conflict has made
the life of policy makers difficult just
as it did in 1973
I recently heard it said at a gathering
rather like this one that the twenties
are unlikely to be as inflationary as
the 1970s on the ground that labor is
less organized and so the risk of a wage
price spirals lower but I want to draw
your attention to 10 important
differences between our contemporary
situation and the situation in the 1970s
one
monetary growth rates were significantly
higher between Q2 2020 and Q2 2021 than
at any point in the 1970s and they
remained in double digits even after
velocity had recovered that was the
policy mistake in my view two
productivity growth is lower today much
lower actually in all oecd countries
than it was in the 70s three demographic
Trends are worse today with
significantly higher dependency ratios
for the fiscal positions are much worse
today with much larger stocks of debt
and projected deficits not least in the
United States
five financial markets are more complex
today and therefore more fragile there
were no such things as liability driven
investment strategies for Pension funds
in the 1970s the events of March 2020
Exposed on my view a comparable
fragility in the U.S treasury market
lots of schaden Freud are directed at
the UK in the last few days but let's be
careful and not assume that this really
is all a consequence of Britain's Monty
Python politics I don't think it is
six then we had pollution now we have
climate change seven are political
stability looks a lot worse than it
seemed even at the time of Watergate
example in a recent poll Americans were
asked do you think the nation's
democracy is in danger of collapse 69 of
Republicans and the same percentage of
Democrats said that they did think so
Ace
current war in Ukraine is lasting much
longer than the War of 1973 approaching
eight months compared with 19 days
so far number nine there's no sign of De
taunt remember detonte in the 1970s in
Cold War II quite the opposite in fact
so there's a non-trivial risk that we
could soon witness a confrontation
between the United States and the
People's Republic of China over Taiwan
tenth and finally
although media attention currently
focuses on the women's protests sweeping
Iranian cities it's worth recalling that
these coincide with the failure of the
attempt to revive the Iran nuclear deal
meaning that the Iranian regime will
likely speed up its effort to acquire a
nuclear weapon increasing the
probability of a war in that region
because no Israeli government whoever is
prime minister is going to countenance a
nuclear-armed Iran so in conclusion we
may get lucky
we may just rerun the 1970s
they're judging by recent events in the
UK we may do it at a rather higher speed
from the barber budget to the winter of
discontent in a matter of weeks rather
than years
but
and this I mean very seriously there is
a scenario in which we get something
closer to the 1940s in which Regional
great power conflicts coalesce into
something like World War III albeit with
smaller armies many unarmed weapon
systems unmanned weapon systems and far
more powerful and accurate bombs
in such a scenario ladies and gentlemen
we'll have to look for guidance not to
Paul volcker but to Mariner Eccles
and no forgotten name and Montague
Norman and we'll look back I suspect on
the phrase quantitative tightening as an
eccentric idea that almost no one was
able to execute the monetary policy
equivalent of Monty Python's Ministry of
silly walks thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign
well thank you now for taking advantage
of the fact that you're not a central
Banker to speak with a little less
moderation
um questions now
keep it snappy identify yourself
questions from any quarter uh we'll
start with the lady in the third room
we have microphones there's a roving
microphone I think
is someone
thank you and by the way could you keep
all our mics on on the panel so that it
saves time thank you very much promo Kim
is from autonomous research
um if anything we've been reminded that
low probability events are not zero
probability events so not to make our
esteem panel rerun your nightmares but
what keeps you up at night and if it is
non-bank institutions what is available
in the richly available toolkit thank
you
thank you we'll take one more question
first
Muhammad are you about to say something
that was an invitation
okay answer that question the class you
want to start on that yeah well I have
already partially answered first of all
nothing keeps me uh awake at night
because I think there is nothing to be
gained by
well unless of course we were to have a
crisis like in the UK then probably I
would also have to make a few
all-nighters
um but uh no I already sort of answered
that I think the nbfi space is clearly
uh uh yeah an issue of of high attention
and there is a an issue also there that
this space of course is not as
homogeneous as the banking space
so I think we have the global financial
crisis 2008 2009 we fixed that by
significantly increasing a capital
buffers and resilience in the banking
sector so that's why I think currently
in sort of the FSB circles there's less
concern about the banking sector
um but fixing the non-bank sector in a
similar manner is not as easy because
it's a very heterogeneous
sort of sample of Institutions with
completely different investment
strategies and what have you so what can
we do well make sure that we dive as
deeply as possible into these what I
called pockets of hidden Leverage
make sure that we open up the data that
is there in this space for instance in
trade repositories so that we bring as
much uh transparency to the process that
is happening there
and then I still would think that sort
of some accidents will happen
unfortunately so I would love to say
that I that I think that that would not
be the case but I think it's it's a
realistic assumption that that things
will happen
um and then we have to fix them because
I don't think it can deviate central
banks from pursuing their inflation
Target that cannot be the case I think
as Andrew has rightly pointed out also
her with his UK example we need to be
our efforts need to be geared towards
separating our monetary assignment as
much as possible from the financial
stability one and monetary policy needs
to be solely geared towards taming
inflation and will have little space to
do anything else clearly as long as
we're still on this side of the
inflation Peak and any sort of prospect
toward of a return toward two percent is
shrouded in huge huge huge uncertainties
thank you class uh there's several
people who've indicated already
we'll start with the gentleman in front
then yourself the minister
we take those three first
at some point we'll give people who are
not white men a chance so just just hold
on a minute peace
good morning Bernardo Rosa from Roseanne
rubini we talked about the potential
conflict between monetary and fiscal
policy but I'd like to speak about
potentially the inconsistencies within
monetary policy until a few years ago it
was unconceivable to think about
increasing interest rates and doing QE
especially because of the contradictory
signals that they would send to the
market now this seems to be
potentially the new Norm in the sense
that you use monetary policy in terms of
interest rates to control for inflation
and potential potentially asset
purchases for either the transmission
mechanism or financial stability
purposes is this becoming a new paradigm
potentially or is just an exception
thank you thank you we'll take the next
question
uh Chris jars on the financial times is
a question for governor Bailey
um as you as you know things are moving
very fast back in London and we have a
new Chancellor and a new uh fiscal
policy which has moved from being the
largest tax cuts in 50 years to now
being tax increases and public spending
cuts how do you see the change in fiscal
policy overnight affecting both the
monetary policy situation in the UK and
the Market's opening on Monday
foreign
panel I have a question for
the central Bankers but also for Neil
Ferguson one element which comes out of
after listening to the Doom list that Mr
Ferguson just provided us is that
monetary policy can be extremely
efficient you can do a great job but it
will not be enough so my simple question
is how do we see going forward a policy
response which counts on all the policy
tools available maybe we need a new G20
thank you
very good I think we will take those
three questions first yeah thank you
maybe
um
also I'd like to say something about the
question one as Krauss already
explained
explained us clearly
um non-bunk Financial intermediaries is
a big
agenda for financial Regulators as well
as Central Bankers in the last three
four years
on the other hand the most dangerous
possibility of financial crisis is
a non-bound financial intermediaries
corrupts or something affecting the
banking sector which would have greater
macroeconomic impact
now
through
whereas a fourth in particular about the
three the current banking sector in
developed countries are much
safer and resilient so that is I think
is
one good point which should be uh
mentioned
now of course the cross-border
inference
made by non-bank Financial
intermediaries in one country
uh to another maybe a
possibility
and because the 2008 Global financial
crisis
initially started in
Riven and others affected Global
Financial
system so we have to be careful but as I
said the strings of the banking sector
is is positive point we have to
think about
uh second question it's a I think a
complicated thing and from our
experience in Japan certainly QE and and
the interest rate uh policy uh
in some case
in the short run could be
used for two
separate tools for two purposes but
apparently in the long run such kind of
separation of QE from interest rate
policy is not it's not
viable I think
the question four is
a bit complicated and
I mean
monetary policy is it is for Price
stability and the central bank's
objectives
price stability and financial stability
and various micro economic matters
including income
distribution and so on so forth
must be
addressed by fiscal policy and structure
for not monetary for so I think there's
clear limit for the central bank to do
basically price stability and a
financial subject thank you Andrew yeah
I'll take well I'll ask Chris Charles's
question I'll just make a very brief
comment on the first question I
Chris I'm sure you'll probably expect me
to say this so I think it's you know
it's good it's good practice for Central
Bank is not to predict financial markets
um but what I will say is this and it's
important
um I issued a statement uh two days
after on the Monday after the fiscal
policy announcement made by the previous
Chancellor on the Friday and I thought I
had to it's not something
you know I make a habits of doing but
given the situation I also don't make a
habit like I think like all my fellow
Governors are commenting on fiscal
policy as a rule because that's not to
cause my job but I made two points on
fiscal policy which I I and they are
deliberately two points which are a
clear relevance I think to the central
bank
one was to emphasize the importance of
sustainability of fiscal policy
and the second which was really part of
that was to emphasize the need in our
case to have the office for Budget
responsibility involved that Flying
Blind is not a way to achieve
sustainability
and those two are very important points
for me the obr is now very much uh back
in the picture
I can tell you that I spoke to Jeremy
Hunt the new Chancellor yesterday and I
can tell you that it was a very clear
and immediate Meeting of Minds between
us about the importance of fiscal
sustainability and the importance of
taking measures to do that of course
there was an important measure taken
yesterday
Jeremy is now working on the what will
be the fiscal statement on the 31st it's
not for me and it's not appropriate for
me to constrain the choices he makes but
the very clear message I were given it's
a clear message for everybody including
its clear message for markets I can tell
you there is a very clear and immediate
Meeting of Minds on the importance of
stability and sustainability
just on the first question Paradigm or
exception the way I'd answer that is
that I think yeah we we have to be in
the business of you know of being able
to do you know meet events that hit us
and we spend a lot of time at central
banks doing contingency planning uh
determining how we can execute
operations so my very clear message is
that we have to be able to
do what we need to do to meet both our
objectives that's both monetary policy
and financial stability and I've just
draw out one point I made earlier
we are now in a world where of course
you know buying guilts at a point when
you are tightening monetary policy and
notwithstanding those comments would
like to start a quantitative easing and
by the way by that by that to be clear
we mean active purchasing
most of us are doing passive runoff now
but at varying speeds depending on what
we hold as as the stock of assets
um but we have to be able to do these
these things because we can't say as I
said earlier sorry can't deal with
financial stability because I'm
tightening monetary policy that's just
not an option for us as a central bank
so we have to have a toolkit that
contains both it's it's nearer to
Paradigm in that sense
but there is a huge premium then on
communication
thank you Andrew Neil
well I I don't really need to tell you
what keeps me awake at night I think I
already made that fairly clear if you
don't wake up to check for alerts uh for
geopolitical escalation you're not
really understanding how the historical
process works
I think if one comes to the question of
is monetary policy sufficient
I'm reminded of conversation I had with
the previous governor of the bank of
England uh Mervin King about a year
before the financial crisis began
and I asked him what will you do if I'm
right in thinking that a crisis in U.S
mortgages is going to have huge
spillover effects and his reply was
immediately monetary policy won't be
sufficient in that contingency we've
thought we've War Games as a lot Andrew
you probably are aware of this and we
know that there will have to be a
substantial role for fiscal policy in
such a scenario as of course proved to
be true and also proved to be true in
the pandemic the idea that monetary
policy was the only game in town which
was briefly fashionable in this
community was always a fantasy
and it brought our relation to
historical reality because historical
reality is the paper I cited mentioned
as I mentioned science is that there are
periods of over 400 years of very
large-scale Central Bank accommodation
of fiscal expansion and that's how it's
worked again and again particularly in
times of geopolitical or financial
crisis
so I think it's fairly clear that if I'm
right that there is a worsening of the
geopolitical situation you can expect
there to be a fiscal and monetary
response the problem is we start from uh
from a fiscal point of view and already
quite stretched position
uh the only consolation is that if one
goes back to British history in the 17th
18th 19th centuries the debt to GDP of
burdens went much higher uh than they
currently are there's truly much more
fiscal room for maneuver uh for
developed economies than most people
recognize because they don't look back
far enough in in the long-term
perspective Japan's debt GDP ratios not
actually completely without a parallel
the problem is it seems to me that it
will be hard having had a pandemic and
then entering a period of geopolitical
turmoil for central banks to cope
with the financing needs of governments
in a way that is not inflationary
and and I think you're bound to see
considerable variance as we saw in the
19th and 20th centuries uh between
countries as to how far they're able to
cope with these fiscal and monetary
expansions without generating inflation
I would anticipate in the quote-unquote
World War III scenario that governments
will increase their interventions in
economic life even more than they
already have controlling prices and not
just controlling Energy prices
intervening in the market in other ways
that's I'm afraid the lesson of history
and and it's why I think of the last 30
years as a strange interwar period a
quiet interlude which we all made the
mistake of thinking was a new normal
the gentleman in front uh the gentleman
at the back there yes yourself the one
who turned around that's right and the
lady in the middle
uh Jim Bullard St Louis fat uh so for
the central Bankers on the panel you
seem to agree that 2023 will be a year
of disinflation
is that because we're still telling the
transitory story or is that because the
uh central banks have taken action that
you think is sufficient to start to
bring down inflation and for Mr
Professor Ferguson if you think of the
pandemic like a war especially from a
U.S perspective lots of fiscal spending
without too much indication of where the
taxes future taxes were going to come
from and uh in a lacks monetary
Authority don't you think we're
switching back to the pre-pandemic
equilibrium with the prospect of divided
government in the U.S and a very active
fed now so it seems like that's a story
about a soft landing and and less
inflation in the U.S going forward
excellent question thanks Jim Bullard
um yes the gentlemen there
something thank you very much Paul
shared it's very understandable that
Central Bankers want to stay in their
Lane and not be seen to be interfering
in any any political processes but given
um the sobering comments from Professor
Ferguson about how much geopolitical
issues can impact on the economy
Financial system and therefore the pilot
Drive the policy responses do you feel
particularly the central Bankers that
there is there are adequate mechanisms
in place for the people the geopolitical
decision makers to be well apprised
ahead of time as they make their
decisions of what the consequences
further down the track may be in terms
of economic outcomes inflationary
outcomes Financial stability outcomes so
you wouldn't be interfering in any sense
but you would be making sure that
geopolitical policy makers were fully
apprised of all of the potential
consequences of those those decisions
and if if that is not the case What
mechanisms can be put in place to to
help that process thank you thank you
next question the lady that's right and
then the Governor from New Zealand
hi tonight
Institute London School of Economics
you've all rightly observed that looking
at the past these are the most
constraining economic monetary and
financial conditions we have faced in a
long time but looking at the future they
may well be the most accommodative we're
looking at at a long time given uh
planetary boundaries and the climate
change that is damaging our economy
these are fixed and exogenous they do
not adjust just because we have more
limited policy space Governor Bailey
spoke in a different context about the
difficulties when monetary or when price
and financial stability hats sits on the
same head how does this translate in the
risks of climate change and tightening
and the higher risks of recession that
are making investment so necessary for
climate action more difficult thank you
you take a final question from the
governor of The Reserve Bank of New
Zealand Adrian Orr and then ngozi
thank you panel uh my question is for uh
Niall
um and I was uh really asking where you
see the risks now that uh the big
countries have woken up and are
tightening our Pace
um do you think that uh the rest of the
world can now will now have to do less
tightening
because the work is being done or more
tightening because our headline
inflation is arising with falling
exchange rates yeah so so where do you
see the risks with your historical
perspective excellent question thank you
and go see or control viola
a wonderful panel I I just wanted to say
you've referred I've heard the central
Bankers refer now and throughout the
meetings to the worries about the tight
labor market and the disappearing labor
which
still needs to be understood could you
just explore this a little bit and what
your biggest biggest fears are what it
means for monetary policy and and the
balance you're trying to achieve I just
want to hear a little bit more and for
Professor Ferguson maybe you can go a
little bit behind the scenes on the
disappearing label and tell us
historically whether you've seen this
and what it means and what we should
understand from it thank you thank you
and why afraid of some of the possible
solutions to deal with this problem
thank you
so we are tight on time so if you can
I'm afraid I have to constrain each of
you to two minutes in your replies
Martin sorry Andrew you want to stop
then two minutes right very quickly uh
to Jim's question I think I think the
story in 23 is a bit of everything
actually so that I mean there clearly is
policy tightening coming through for all
of us
um I I mean I I say this although you
know I'm in danger of being sort of
being told that I probably said this six
months ago because for on the energy
front for inflation not to to come off
Energy prices have got to go on Rising
and you know I sort of sincerely hope
that doesn't happen
um and then of course I met what I was
saying earlier of course the the other
things equal point about second round
effects and we're going to have to stay
very focused on the the risks and second
round effects I want to stay in Lane the
second question I said the interesting
question I mean I'd probably go back to
where crystalina started I mean I think
there is a very important role and I
think you know the IMF is a very
important part of this of pointing out
the economics of this
but I would make the points I've you
know I've sat in many International
meetings
um you know as
Klaus and uh and harihika do
um you know we do not say well you know
you can't pursue a you know you can't uh
pursue a response to Russia because
inflation's a bit High I mean yeah we're
all we all recognize the critical
importance
of what is going on in Ukraine and we
have to deal with the consequences of it
on climate change I mean I would say
this I think that we have to factor
climate change into our everyday
business both as regulators and as
monetary policy makers so that is why
we've put so much emphasis on France
where it's been a leader in this in
terms of the economic modeling and I
would just encourage please support us
and keep doing this because it's
critically important
all the labor market is a great question
I mean I'd really be interested in Nas
for years on the history of this because
I think it's where we could really
benefit from from that what we're seeing
I'll talk in the UK is is an increase in
inactivity in other words people who are
choosing not to work it's older people
and the labor force survey tells us that
the the biggest reason when they're
asked is long-term health conditions now
I've just finished by saying we don't
know I've heard three possible
explanations of this in public health
and from Health economists long covered
people with pre-existing health
conditions who were confident to be in
the labor force when covert wasn't there
but are not confident at the moment when
covert is there and then thirdly sadly
that our health you know our public
health and how our health systems are
not treating people as promptly uh now
given in a covered world and with the
consequences as they were in the past
and of course that sadly means you know
people with other conditions are
becoming more unwell and not able to
work I don't know the mix but those but
of course they're all possible
thank you close yeah
um first on 2023 inflation excellent
question I think Jim but if I if you go
back for a moment to the first slide
that I showed in the Euro area a lot of
inflation is the energy shock negative
surprise well if you look at Energy
prices obviously they started to rise
already
in the second half of 21 when Mr Putin
started to play with us
um but there is this huge spike in
February March surrounding the invasion
which by the very nature of it will sort
of Peter out of the data in 2023 now if
Neil is right and there were to be a
significant escalation of the conflict
in 2023 then of course you cannot
exclude new energy shocks but they would
then have to take Energy prices to even
dramatically higher levels than they
currently are if that is not the case
then I think say to responding was it is
a reasonable assumption that inflation
will come down in 2023 the big question
is how much and how quickly and how
strong will the traditional let's say
Philips curve effect be when our economy
begins to slow down and on that I think
there are sort of various there is a
range of views on on how strong that
affect will be and indeed also Andrew
mentioned we we started changing our
policy posture in Euro area in December
21 so if you take the normal 18 to 24
months yes in the second half of 23 I
would also expect that some of that
changing monetary policy posture begins
to to kick in in the inflation
developments in the Euro area as well
um on the the point of the war and I
have little to add to what Andrew said
with one exception
the sanctions that sort of were
constructed in the in the course of 2022
from my end there was I have observed
that there was communication beforehand
also well with financial authorities on
what would be the consequences of these
sanctions how would they buy it how can
we construct them in a manner that we
don't shoot ourselves in the food and
create a financial instability
events in our own sort of financial
system Etc so there the communication
has been there
but of course if it comes to questions
about pushing buttons and launching
missiles I I'm not I don't expect that
they will call the chair of the
financial stability board before taking
taking such a decision last very brief
point on the labor market we did not in
the Euro area have so much decline in
labor force participation than in other
parts of the world simply because a lot
of the fiscal support
in during the pandemic was actually on
the job support it was support for the
employers to keep the employees so that
they that would continue to receive
their salary unlike the U.S where it was
much more Income Support so we didn't
have this huge decline it's less of an
urgent our labor market is very very
tight continues to be very tight
the old elderly with health issues that
are reluctant to come back yes that
issue is clearly also there in the Euro
area but overall it's to a lesser extent
than elsewhere
product just inflation in 2023 as well
as labor markets the conditions
I totally agree with with Klaus just one
comment on climate change I think this
is a long-term Challenge and we have to
address this
probably the most
serious and important issue in this
Century so by the way Bank of Japan
recently introduced a special facility
to provide funding to financial
institutions which Finance uh academic
change mitigation projects and this
facility will continue at least
in the next 10 years
now four very brief responses I know
we're out of time to jimbila I guess I
struggle to believe in the story of
returning to pretty close to two percent
pce by 2024 because it needs nothing
else to happen because and that's only
in economics that nothing else happens
uh you need the war to stop for one
thing the war is not going to stop
there's absolutely no obvious way in
which this war ends and as I said there
is a significant risk of escalation in
other in other regions uh I think your
points about divided government and a
more active fed is is interesting I
don't know that it leads me to expect a
soft landing at though and the reason is
that I remember Alan meltzer's account
of of the fed's uh conduct of monetary
policy in the 70s nothing that the this
fed has done
so far differs
from what Arthur Burns's fed did
just to be clear so it's all very well
to invoke the name of Paul volcker but
let's just look at the burns fed's
performance they raise rates but when
the going got tough they paused or
reversed course and nothing has happened
to date to persuade me that that won't
happen again and I believe it will
happen when the first signs of trouble
in New York
uh in the the U.S bond market appear
and we'll look back and say ah what
happened in London was actually just a
warning of what was going to happen uh
in New York you will not get to a
non-accelerating inflation rate of
unemployment but whatever it is I don't
know Larry says six percent before
Financial stability issues force you to
change course
um in the UK now second Point climate
change is inflationary
and so are most of the things that we're
doing to mitigate climate change
let that sink in
uh it to Adrian Orr the risks of the
rest of the world are that the FED will
continue pursuing this uh uh supposedly
Volker as policy the dollar will
strengthen uh as it as it did during
Paul Walker's uh time in the early 80s
and that will put intense pressure on
the rest of the world especially the
rest of the world that's indebted in
dollars this is a point that keto
gopanoff has made rightly and others
have made finally the good news is that
I think the FED will blink uh and at
that point all these Trends will reverse
themselves uh rather as happened in the
mid 80s
I think that the quest
you raised about the labor markets are
super interesting one because it's very
hard to find in the past uh societies
with such uh elderly populations and low
fertility as we currently see in most of
the world except Africa 95 of the
projected increase in population in the
world between now and the incentives is
going to be in sub-Saharan Africa and so
the huge question that comes to my mind
is not just about uh Public Health
though I think Andrew Bailey's right to
emphasize that I think we have an even
bigger problem with this in the United
States than in Europe but there's a huge
question about immigration which goes I
think largely unaddressed here
legal immigration into the United States
has effectively stopped illegal
immigration is going uh gangbusters but
the legal variant has basically stopped
and this looks like a huge policy owned
goal it's also inflationary I mean it
you can't really expect the U.S labor
market to be responsive to the needs of
uh of business if if you don't have any
significant legal immigration so I think
the huge unanswered question and it's
posed not just by the issues I talked
about it's also posed by climate change
is
is there going to be large-scale
immigration from Africa in the coming
Decades of this century and if so to
where will it be managed or will be
chaotic those are huge questions they're
beyond the scope of monetary policy as
most of the things I've I've talked
about are but that's the reality of the
historical process that central banks
have to contend with many more
challenges than the the relatively
narrowly defined ones of price stability
and financial stability
thank you and it does really bring us
back to Fair Carlo part one's question
on long-term fiscal policy it's a
fundamental challenge we now face uh
Jacob you'd like to say have a quick
word we are just very few words first
there was a question what keeps us up at
night I think those of you who listen to
the discussion got a lot of reasons to
keep us up at night
um
there was a lot of discussion about
monetary policy as if this is
the key
most of the crisis today do not emanate
for monetary policy except for inflation
most will not be solved by monetary
policy
comes the question therefore that the
former Minister padwan mentioned so what
do we do what other tools do we need to
have I don't think that it is another
Forum or another discussion among people
I think the real issue is what we did
not discuss in order to have flexible
economy you need to have structural
policies there is no appetite to do it
at all we have here negozi the head of
WTO who just reported not today that
trade in the world is going to grow at
the slowest Pace since the previous deep
crisis and trade growth is associated
with global growth so we are in deep
trouble it's not to be solved by a
meeting of Minister of Finance and
ministers or and governors
coronation and myself are old enough to
remember when we met first either Plaza
in Louisville this was a different world
where you thought that you can do
everything by either Central Bank
Governors or ministries of Finance
without the trade ministers and the
other ministers who deal with structural
issues it will not come up so the issue
is not let's find a place to meet but
let's discuss what to discuss please
thank you for uh
to all of our panelists and please join
me in thanking them for a very
thoughtful discussion
[Applause]